dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly jean is a here today
we are going to talk about a rigorous
scientific topic none other than the
creation of the perfect selfie photo by
definition selfies are made by us which
means that these are typically
short-range photos and due to the
perspective distortion of the camera
lens we often experience unpleasant
effects like the heavy magnification of
the nose and the forehead and get this
this technique enables us to take a
photo and after that edit the perceived
camera distance for it without changing
anything else basically algorithmic
beautification this technique works the
following way we analyze the photo and
try to figure out how distant the camera
was when the photo was taken then we
create a digital model of the
perspective camera and create a 3d model
of the face this is the process that
mathematicians like to call fitting it
means that if we know the optics of
perspective cameras we can work
backwards from the input photo that we
have and find an appropriate setup that
would result in this photo then we will
be able to adjust this distance to even
out the camera less distortions but
that's not all because as we have the
digital 3d model of the face we can do
even more for instance we can also
rotate it around in multiple directions
to build such a 3d model we typically
try to locate several where recognizable
hotspots on the face such as the chin
eyebrows no stem the region under the
nose eyes and lips
however if these hotspots lead to a poor
3d representation of the human face the
authors added a few more of these
hotspots to the detection process this
still takes less than five seconds
earlier we also talked about a neural
network based technique that judged our
selfie photos by assigning a score to
them I would absolutely love to see how
that work would react to a before and
after photo that comes from this
technique this way we can formulate this
score as a maximization problem and as a
result we could have an automated
technique that truly creates the perfect
selfie photo through this warping
operation
the best kind of evaluation is when we
let reality be our judge and use images
that were taken closer or farther away
and compare the output of this technique
against them these through images bear
the ground truth label throughout this
video the differences are often barely
perceptible and to provide a better
localization of the error sum difference
images are shown in the paper if you are
into stereoscopy there's also an entire
section about that as well the authors
also uploaded an interactive version of
their work online that anyone can try
free of charge so as always your
scholarly before and after selfie
experiments are more than welcome in the
comment section whether you are already
subscribed to the series or just
subscribing now which you should
absolutely do make sure to click the
bell icon to never miss an episode we
have lots of amazing works coming up in
the next few videos hope to see you
there again thanks for watching and for
your generous support now see you next
time
[Music]